Materials make
distinctive sounds
when you hit and scratch them.
[HITTING SOUNDS]
These sounds can tell us
how objects behave when we
physically interact with them.
They can convey
whether an object
is hard or soft, smooth or
rough, and rigid or deformable.
In this work, we consider the
material understanding task
of predicting what
sounds something
will make when you hit it.
We give an algorithm
a silent video
of someone striking
things with a drumstick.
We ask it to produce a plausible
soundtrack to go along with it.
To perform this task
well, the algorithm
has to recognize the
materials that are being hit
and the actions that
are being performed.
But we don't explicitly
tell it about these things.
Instead, it has to learn about
them by recognizing patterns
in the raw audio visual signal.
Our algorithm takes a
video sequence as input
and it predicts a corresponding
sequence of sound features.
After a network
predicts sound features,
we synthesize a waveform
by matching these features
to a database of impact sounds
and transferring the best
matches.
Here are some soundtracks
that our algorithm produced.
[HITTING SOUNDS]
To help understand
what our model's doing,
we can look at the video
clips in our database
that it's transferring
audio from.
These are the audio
clips whose sound
features are most similar to
those predicted by our model.
[SCRATCHING SOUNDS]
[HITTING SOUNDS]
[BANGING SOUNDS]
Instead of synthesizing a
waveform by transferring sounds
from a database, we can directly
invert the sound features
with a simple parametric
synthesis method.
This can help us
understand what information
is contained in the
sound features that
are model predicted.
[BANGING SOUNDS]
Our algorithm can get confused
when the motion of a drumstick
resembles a hit but it does
not actually strike a surface.
[BANGING SOUNDS]
We conducted a human study
where we asked people
to distinguish real impact
sounds from sounds that
were synthesized by our model.
We found that our sound
predictions fooled participants
more often than those
of baseline methods,
including simple
image matching models.
[SCRATCHING AND BANGING SOUNDS]